hello everyone and welcome back to the
feeder Grand Prix it's Maxima sherrilyn
Grove with the white pieces against the
UH opponent even yesterday we've seen a
game where nipple one
maxime tried his groom full defense and
nipple was able to break through it and
now Maxime has to win on demand with the
white piece we don't have any new photos
we only have the ones we saw yesterday
so now we're not going to be enjoying
any today but it's very interesting that
well that's what I meant in in
yesterday's video that nipple is a very
peculiar player most players would
choose a very calm opening something
that you know can ensure that you can
easily tre down and go for a simple end
game or something like that but not
napal napal won a game against the green
fold and now he plays the groom fought
against Maxime and it's a very different
groom fault than the one they played
yesterday yeah so without further ado
let's check it out Maxime opens with d4
I'll be have Knight to f6 c4 g6 and now
the early h4 by Maxine and it's a very
interesting that this move has only been
played a few times but only in 2019 so I
don't know if this has anything to do
with with alpha zero or which is the
game changer or and everything that's
been going on around alpha zero but it's
well it's very interesting that h4 has
never been played before and alpha zero
always plays h4 pretty much against
every opening and now in 2019 people
have started playing it but okay Bishop
g7 with Knight to c3 d5 now so the groom
fold with the inclusion of h4 and now h5
well h5 by white we have Knight captures
on age five and now C captures on d5 and
it's interesting but Knepper already
faced this as black against Alexander II
shook in the Amsterdam rapid tournament
in April that game was won by one by
neppo so probably Maxime prepared
something very special with East six
nipple continues in the same fashion he
did against the Grisha but now D
captures a nice X was played by terrific
but here we have G for ng 4 is a new
move so already as of move seven we have
a completely new game and it is quite
quite
game with night back to f6 by neppo and
now D captures any sex with bushel
captures an e6 and now II for advancing
the pawns even further in the center and
now
Knepper just grabs the g4 pawn with
Bishop captures energy for with f3
Bishop goes back to e 6 and now Maxine
is down upon but he he does have a
massive Center which is well you always
have a massive Center in when you play
against the groom fault but here you are
also down upon and here Bishop to g5
it's well you could try d5 right away
but after black movies the bishop
you can continue Bishop g5 h6 let's say
Bishop e3 and now black will still play
c6 like he did in the game and it
doesn't help you anything you cannot go
d6 you could but the knight will just go
here
black will Castle to safety and this
point will be undermined later as the e5
square is nicely guarded by by the d7
night so the point will be is a to
advanced so after Bishop d6 where Bishop
to g5 Maxime is still flexible with the
pawns in the center h6 Bishop back the
e3 and the now c6 taking control of d5
we have Knight G - E - and now not
castling right away but first Bishop the
c4 just uh well if the White Knight for
example comes to g3 then you can trade
down even further we have Queen to c2
now comes the Queen to a5 and Knight to
f4 captures captures as was planned and
Knights to a6 preparing Knight the b4 so
maxime stops it with a three and now
Knight back to c7 and King F to the King
it will be much safer there and also you
can just transfer the rooks to the King
side if the black King castles but neppo
decides to go for g5 so pushes the knife
for the back the knight can come to e2
for example e - now III to f5 fi will be
an excellent square for the knight but
first before pushing the black Queen
further back Knight the Queen to a6 and
now not Knight to e2 but rather night to
d3 probably with the idea of going
Knight a c5 or a5 perhaps in some lines
but
now perhaps knife the eetu was more
correct with the idea of 94 to f5 here
with Queen to c4 not waiting for night
to the c5 and now comes look a to C 1 we
have Knight to d7 preparing this f5
thrust and not night the beat pushing
the Queen back with Queen back to e6 and
now Knight to e2 so now the night is
coming to g3 and then to f5 only only a
little bit later than it should have and
the the situation on the clock is 48
minutes for MBL and one hour for nipple
we have Knights the b5 now going for the
a3 pawn we have a 4 pushing the right
back and now Knight to d6 so a free Rema
nuvaring of the night
we have night the g3 night the night
from d6 now controls f5 so this
shouldn't be a problem but also it
supports the f5 thrust so f5 a very nice
pawn sacrifice by nipple it completely
eliminates white's strong Center we have
pawn captures on f5 and now Queen to d5
and I centralizing move with the Queen
and now for the moment material is equal
but White's pawn structure is shattered
in the center and here if you just do
nothing if you wait a black will just
castle bring the rook over to the F file
pick up the f5 pawn and well just
continue the game again being up upon
and having a better position so maxim
went to Knight to c4 it is the strongest
move recommended by the engine but this
is again one of those positions where
the strongest move recommended by the
engine will not achieve victory since it
allows nepeta to easily trade down into
a into a better endgame so here Knepper
just trades with Knight captures Queen
captures we have Queen captures rook
captures and Knight to d6 attacking the
rook and da for pawn we have looked the
c5 and now Knepper could go for the a4
pawn but this would allow Maxime to
further complicate matters with f6
attack the bishop after Bishop captures
rook a5 you still prevent the black king
from castling and with the two rooks
still being out of out of commission it
would be possible to you know look for
some poison in
position for example if there should be
seven you can even go D 5 and if C
captures Bishop D for you attack the
rook now after Luke - h7 you can go look
the a1 and it's a really really messed
up position where anything can happen
and it's not going to be easy to even
draw this with with either side so it
anything can happen here so nepo just
says i don't care about your opponent
just gonna castle we have a 5 by
magazine and now Knight to d5 going
after the bishop here
maxime pushed a 6 here and it was in
this position that maxime beaugeois grab
and young opponent she agreed to a draw
I don't think neppo actually offered the
draw even though he's better in this
position I think it was actually Maxine
who offered it because he knows that
there is no way to do anything well you
can only lose this with white you can't
do anything other than that you can draw
or lose so I think it was a Maxine who
offered the draw as the move 30 they are
beyond move 30 so I guess it's okay to
offer a draw here but this is not the
end for Maxine there's still a way for
him to read you the candidates
tournament let me just show why for
example if Luke 88 comes with a double
attack on the bishop and if pawn
captures you're just gonna capture the
bishop b8 Queen the rook can move and
now you capture the night and after look
out for some before there's nothing
white can do here the d4 point is under
attack you have a past a pawn so if if
any one will win this it's going to be
black so after a six-day trudeau game
and nipple now proceeds to the finals of
the feeder grand prix and there he will
face well either dark navara or way he
depends on who wins their semi-final
match it's still being played so I don't
know how game 2 will end up we're
definitely going to check it out but if
nipple wins the finals then nipple gets
the spot in the candidates tournament
and the MBL is out for sure if neppo
fails to win the feeder Grand Prix
finals then MVL gets a spot in the
tournament so there's still a
possibility for both of them to reach
the tournaments for example if neppo
loses in the finals then MVL goes into
the candidates tournament but probably
nipple will be given the
the wild card so he will probably also
qualify that way but you know it's gonna
be interesting we're just gonna have to
wait and see so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it a very interesting
approach to the groom field especially
that three h4 move which you know I do
believe alpha zero had a lot to say
about that and that's why everyone is
playing it now into the in 2019 but then
again it could be it could be a lot of
other things I would like to think
expanding your world and Boris Cogan for
a contributor to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too in my previous video serum
think of for watching and I will see you
soon continuing with the coverage of the
feeder Grand Prix checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and as always
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day